- Well Sheldon really my first name
but they call me Mack Sheldon.
- (Mark) Got it.
- M-A-C-K.
Gonna have to be letting them
know that for the records.
They be wanting to spell it M-A-C.
Make sure if you spell
it on, spell it on camera
make sure you put it M-A-C-K.
- (Mark) You got it.
All right, Mack Sheldon.
Mack, where'd you where'd
you grow up originally?
Where are you from>
- Right here in Oakland, California.
From Oakland, across the bridge.
- (Mark) Yeah, and tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents as a kid?
- Yeah, I did, I did.
I have a Chinese mama.
She's an awesome mama.
I got a dad that was awesome too.
- (Mark) Good childhood?
- Good childhood, I can't complain.
- (Mark) No abuse, no
crazy traumatic stuff?
- No, nope, nope, nope.
- (Mark) So did you have role models
as a kid growing up, showing you the game?
- Yeah, players was my role models.
You know, pimps and
players was my role models.
I didn't really take to the gangsta thing.
I wanted to be a player,
I wanted to be a pimp.
- (Mark) And growing up in
Oakland you had plenty of those.
- Yeah, even though I had a
good mama and a good daddy
I chose to be in the game.
- (Mark) And where, what,
at what age did you start?
- I started like 18, I
waited till I was 18.
- (Mark) How'd you get your first girl?
- I just, my mind just, my mind just
was like get you a girl turn her out
and I just called the chick at the club.
It wasn't like I was her boyfriend.
Then eventually she just, you know,
she eventually she knew
what she had to do.
I reached a ride through the whole show
with her in the car.
Talked to my peer and friends.
And then bam, it just happened.
- (Mark) You got advice from other pimps
- I did, I did.
I got a little advice,
but you're gonna learn
from your first ho though.
Your first ho, that's how
you gonna learn the game.
- (Mark) What kind of
stuff did she teach you?
- She just come back in every night
and tell you what pimps said to her,
what tricks did to her,
what tricks wanted,
stuff like that.
- (Mark) And she would bring
you how much of her money?
- All of it, every dime.
I got that, every dime.
- (Mark) And what did she get out of it?
- I mean, she just get
me and I'd look out for.
You know, she needs something to eat,
she needs clothes, we'd go out sometime.
Might let her off to go
to a concert or something.
- (Mark) So it's like your her boyfriend.
- Yeah.
- (Mark) How many girls did you have?
- At one time about four.
About four deep at one time.
- (Mark) Have you ever
done any prison time?
- Yeah, I did some prison time before.
'Cause eventually I started selling drugs.
I went to jail for narcotics.
- (Mark) Yeah, were drugs
a part of the pimping game?
- Nah, nah, nah, not really.
When you pimp, when you
pimp you just really wanna
just pimp, you know.
And then after I got through pimping
then I kind of got into the drug game.
- (Mark) How long were you a pimp?
- Oh Lord, many years, many years.
I pimped for a living.
I went from coast to coast,
like butter on toast.
Kick states in the ass with this pimping.
- (Mark) So you started at
18 and how old are you now?
- I'm 61 now.
- (Mark) 61 now, so you.
- Yeah, but I done bowed out the game,
I done bowed out gracefully
a long time ago though.
See always just people call me a pimp.
I say, no I'm not a pimp, pimps have hos,
macks have what they wanna have.
That's why they call me Mack Sheldon.
- (Mark) So you're a mack?
- I'm a mack.
- (Mark) What's the difference
between a mack and a pimp?
- Pimps have hos and macks
have what they wanna have.
- (Mark) No, but technically
what's the difference?
- That's my philosophy.
- (Mark) A pimp is a more stylish, suave
and debonair version of a pimp, right?
- I don't know, I think a mack is.
- (Mark) I mean a mack is,
I'm sorry a mack is a more.
- Yeah, I think a mack is.
I think you gotta be the pimp
before you can become a mack.
- (Mark) Right, so a pimp can
eventually build himself up
to be mack status?
- Yeah. I think you got to
be, I mean I can only speak
for me, my philosophy and
I think you gotta be pimp
and then when you graduate to a mack.
That's how I look at it.
Like I said, I done bowed out gracefully.
Pimps have hos, macks
have what they wanna have.
So right now I just
have what I wanna have.
- (Mark) So when you were rolling
what kind of cars were you driving?
- I had Cadillacs, Benz.
Like right now I got two Jaguars.
I just bought a BMW.
- (Mark) What are the personality
traits that's most useful
in terms of being a pimp for you?
- Just being smooth, suave dressing.
- (Mark) Are you married?
- Nah, I'm not married.
- (Mark) Were you married ever?
- I got married once
before, a long time ago.
Had a daughter.
Yeah, I'm not married.
- (Mark) And how does a
married life and pimping
both coexist?
- I mean, it don't exist,
it don't go together to me.
I think if you gonna pimp you just need
to just straight laced pimp.
- (Mark) What's more important
to you, love or money?
- Money.
Money, I mean I like love too though.
Right now, right now.
See I'm much older now so
I'm a little different now.
You know, back in the
day it was like pimping,
I thought I was going to PIDI.
- (Mark) Your girls
white, black, Hispanic?
- I had both kinds.
I had white, I had black.
- (Mark) You'd have sex with the girls?
- Of course.
- (Mark) How do you handle a girl
when she gets a little too,
when she gets out of line?
- You know, I try to not
to put my hands on them.
I mean back in the day I probably did.
Not too much though.
I try to whoop them by letting
that ho show whoop them.
I keep on the whole show for
hours and hours and hours.
- (Mark) So that reputation
that pimps use intimidation
or violence or whatever to get the girls.
- Some, you know everybody pimp different.
You know some pimps do
that, some pimps don't.
You got soft shoe pimps,
you got gorilla pimps.
You know, I try not to
put my hands on them.
I didn't really like that.
- (Mark) So the laws have
changed a lot since back
when you were doing it.
Is that why you got out?
- Yeah, but see no one catched
him and he went to jail
for pimping and pandering.
In my mind, you don't
go to jail for pimping,
you go to jail for mispimping.
Like a friend of mine
told me that one time.
Said you don't go to jail for pimping,
you go to jail for mispimping.
- (Mark) Is part of the
game having the girls
figure out ways to get
money from the Johns?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- (Mark) It's not simply just
sex for money, sometimes.
- Nah, nah, you got to know how to talk.
They gotta talk for it.
They gotta talk for it,
they gotta perform for.
Gotta put on the act.
They know how to do it.
- (Mark) Figure out what guys have money?
- Yeah, well, some girls
even know how to steal.
- (Mark) That's what I'm saying.
- They know how to feel
on your dick with one hand
and be in your pocket with the other hand.
- (Mark) What's the longest
you'd had a girl stay with you?
- About four or five years.
Yeah, one of my turnouts.
Maybe longer than that.
- (Mark) But what do you
think the core of the pimp
and prostitute relationship is?
Is it that she's looking for a boyfriend?
Is it she's just looking
for a father figure
that she never had?
- No, to me some women are
just born to pay a pimp.
Some hos is just born to pay a pimp.
Just want to be a pimp,
wanna be with a pimp.
- (Mark) What's the
craziest thing you've seen
in all your years of doing this?
- Oh man, that's a good question.
It's been so long since I did it.
As far as what?
- (Mark) Like the, just the thing
that makes you shake your head at.
- Is what tricks want.
When they come on and
tell me what a trick want.
- (Mark) Yeah, that's crazy, right?
- Oh man, crazy.
- (Mark) I've heard it all, I think.
- Yeah, yeah, me too.
They want they dick beat,
they want to be shitted on,
they wanna be pissed on.
They wanna do some sick stuff, man.
I guess that's why they call them tricks.
- (Mark) And these are guys with money.
- Yeah, these are guys with big money.
And don't want they wives
to know what they fetish is.
- (Mark) How has the game
changed since you started?
- Oh man, the game done changed.
These youngsters, to me they took the art
out of the pimping.
You know, I mean, just
like I'm dressed like now,
you look across the street,
if you was to look across the street
and you see how the pimps dress now.
See back in the day, used
to be able to tell a pimp
from a drug dealer, or
a pimp from a gangsta.
See a player gonna dress like me,
you know, but nowadays the youngsters is,
they ain't accepting no news.
If you knock a ho, if somebody,
if I knock somebody for they ho
and then I caught myself
serving them the new
they don't want to accept the new.
See there's rules and
regulations to pimping.
Back then, I don't know about now.
These youngsters, they be like,
I ain't accepting no new, that's my ho.
I knocked her fair and square.
You know, so yeah.
They took the art out of pimping to me.
- (Mark) Yeah.
What are you proudest of in your life?
- What am I what?
- (Mark) What are you
proudest of in your life?
- Where am I proud?
- (Mark) What are you proud of?
- You know, I just believe like right now
just keep it real, play fair,
treat people how I wanna be treated.
- (Mark) All right.
- That's about it you know.
I ain't never spoke on
camera like this before
so it's kinda, it got hard.
- (Mark) It's okay, you did a great job.
All right, Mack Sheldon.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- All right, all right Mark.
- (Mark) And good luck with
wherever you go from here.
- All right, I'm going
straight up to the top.
- (Mark) Thanks man.
- All right Mark.